todos devem ter lembrança de quando
foram alunos
aliás todos aqui são foram logo até
voltaram à cena é eu particularmente sou
professor então tem uma coisa que eu
faço questão de lembrar sempre é das
boas aulas que eu tive mas
principalmente das ruins e eu acho que
os profissionais de várias áreas
deveriam pensar um pouco nisso né na
área de saúde por exemplo é sempre bom
que um médico lembra do tempo em que foi
paciente e um psicólogo lembra disso
também porque se colocar no lugar do
outro
é fundamental para que haja comunicação
para que haja compreensão a as
lembranças de escola que a gente tem são
de todos os tipos e certamente vocês
tiveram os professores que nem eu tive
eu me lembro de um que diante de uma
situação em que ele não conseguia
controlar uma bagunça na aula ele fez
aquela famosa ameaça se vocês não
pararem eu vou registrar no caderno como
al adha
isso criava um pânico nem os alunos se
olhavam assim começava a se colocar uns
contra os outros a culpa é tua que eu
vou acabar indo mal na minha aula mas eu
fico imaginando o ponto de vista de quem
está sendo um profissional naquilo que
essa pessoa está fazendo
já imaginou um médico nessa situação
dizendo que o paciente olha se eu
conseguir meu procedimento à risca eu
vou colocar como cirurgia realizada
mas e quando a matéria dada e não é
entendida
será que tudo o que se ensina e se
aprende
aí começam as questões da educação não
posso achar que eu dei uma boa aula se
meu aluno não aprendeu
é como um médico considerar que fez uma
cirurgia de sucesso apesar de o paciente
ter morrido
então com esses pequenos detalhes a
gente começa a se dar conta de que o
problema da educação é o problema que a
gente vê repercutindo na sociedade cada
vez a gente tem mais gente falando mas
cada vez a gente tem menos gente ouvindo
e tem pouca gente se comunicando e
compreendendo eu gosto de ler biografias
a ele uma biografia sobre o crise da
cunha o autor de os sertões
eu gosto de detalhes que a gente percebe
na vida das pessoas assim o cliente um
homem que passou por mudanças muito
constantes
sua vida porque ele perdeu a mãe cedo
então ele teve que morar em muitos
lugares muitas escolas diferentes
mas em vez de tirar disso uma
experiência ruim puxa não tenha uma
constância ele tira disso uma
adaptabilidade uma capacidade de chegar
em um lugar e entender aquilo porque
eles instrumentalizou com o contato com
a diferença e isso talvez tenha sido
responsável para quando ele chegou na
região de canudos quando ele foi cobrir
aquela guerra para escrever seu livro os
sertões
ele percebeu o grande equipe que estava
acontecendo ali que ali havia uma
diferença de interpretação ali na
massacraram 25 mil pessoas porque houve
incompreensão falta de comunicação
uma notícia se espalhava pelo brasil
inteiro lá no meio da baía viu uma
rebelião de monarquistas tentando
derrubar a recém instaurada república
brasileira não era não era verdade
fake news aconteceu o massacre por causa
de fake news
cada aluno cada paciente é diferente é
quando a gente começa a prestar atenção
nas pessoas né e aí nós lembramos das
nossas próprias experiências e mantermos
essas experiências à tona faz com que a
gente preste mais atenção no nosso
próprio trabalho
na escola cada aluno é diferente não me
lembro do tempo de colégio assim eu
tinha colegas que desde pequeno já
sabiam desde sempre que queria fazer da
vida de um outro que falavam sobre a
futura profissão outros falavam
especializações e olhando no meio
daquilo me sentindo perdido
eu não tinha a menor idéia do que queria
fazer inclusive porque eu pensava assim
quase que a universidade era uma espécie
de um novo colégio apenas quente mudar
de escola e continuar estudando não
consegui enxergar isso como uma
preparação para a vida
e aí a gente vai dando conta de como não
tratam as diferenças da gente não é como
nos pés não percebem as nossas
diferenças
eu acabei optando por fazer geologia eu
conversei acham que um profissional os
tempos antes da inscrição do vestibular
achei interessante que ele falou e
também aquela coisa da gente muito
interessante a gente acha interessante
fazer uma escolha diferente né então o
problema que não sabe explicar muito bem
o que é isso que vai fazer mas as
pessoas achavam muito interessante
vamos fazer uma cara um sei né
mas em geral também não entende mas a
gente entra na faculdade a universidade
é uma coisa fascinante a gente tem
contato com gente tão diferente
são assuntos variados são outros cursos
a gente começa a descobrir coisas que
nunca viu na vida que mundo fascinante
que entrar na universidade
o problema real a aula era muito chato
não conseguir identificar com nada que
aconteceu na aula é esse conflito mas eu
demora um tempo até a gente perceber
isso porque eu acho que de uma certa
maneira a gente está acostumado que a
aula é chata ponto
então a gente não faz o processo crítico
é tentar entender o que a gente está
fazendo de errado ali naquele momento
aí eu comecei a passar por muitas
experiências naquela coisa no ano
seguinte resolvi entrar no curso de
educação física também para duas
faculdades ao mesmo tempo
ao mesmo tempo comecei a trabalhar de
revisor do jornal
nisso eu comecei a perceber que as duas
faculdades que estava fazendo não fazia
nenhum sentido pra mim não tinha nenhum
prazer eu acho que eu me lembro como se
fosse hoje eu estava num mau de cálculo
me lembro de me retirar daquela aula
olhando assim tem alguém louco que o
professor passou eu sentar num banco de
praça e fica pensando porque ela tem que
ser tão chato
gostaria tanto ter uma agradável é para
começar até ao agradável teria que ser
de alguma coisa que eu acho agradável
como por exemplo a livros música línguas
naquele momento o céu se abriu tocaram
as trombetas e uma voz disse
e por que tu não estás fazendo letras
fez uma transferência de curso é
impressionante quando a gente anuncia
isso é que vai transferir se transferir
de curso como isso mexe com as pessoas
que não têm nada a ver com isso
as pessoas fazem umas caras estranhas
mas como assim
uma pessoa está começando um caminho vai
largar meio né é assim foi um tempo
jogado fora eu perguntava mas como eu
estava vindo não tinha morrido naquele
tempo a gente está vindo a gente não
joga tempo fora porque as experiências
são acumuladas para coisas que a gente
nunca sabe de que forma vai usá las mais
adiante né
e aí estou cursando o curso de letras de
repente alguém me diz que tem além do
meu trabalho eu vou fazer
olha tem uma vaga para dar aula de
inglês numa cidade vizinha que eu era
bem daquelas pessoas assim vamos lá todo
mundo quiser vamos lá eu vou tocando as
coisas depois eu penso e quando eu vejo
que diante dos meus primeiros alunos
eu estava cursando licenciatura eu não
tinha a menor ideia se eu queria ou não
ser professor tinha que resolver isso
comigo primeiro mas aí que
circunstâncias acontecem universidade em
greve e eu resolvo parar tudo e fazer um
mochilão eu vou à europa eu vou
trabalhar estudar e viajar porque não
tinha dinheiro então tinha que trabalhar
constantemente e essa é daquelas horas
assim que a gente se descobre a
capacidade da diversidade na argentina
onde a gente fazia tudo um pouco desde
cozinha colheita é trabalho de
carregador de tacos de coffin campeonato
limpeza né eu nem me ter qualquer coisa
se fazia e essa coisa que a gente começa
a se dar conta que tudo improviso ele é
normal de uma certa forma que a gente se
entrega à diversidade a novidade mas o
mais fascinante são as pessoas que a
gente vai conhecendo as experiências que
a gente vai trocando né
a gente tem uma sensação de
amadurecimento de muitos anos numa
viagem quando uma viagem intensa desse
jeito eu acho que eu conheci das pessoas
mais fascinantes da minha vida quando eu
estava viajando e se me permite a
inconfidência uma delas é hoje reitor
desta universidade a
mas quando voltei eu tava pensando
principalmente que eu vou fazer da minha
vida vou terminar meu curso
não sei se você professora não sei como
funciona isso
mas aquelas coincidências que acontece
com todo mundo é sempre tem parece que
tem um anjinho que arruma as coisas pra
gente eu antes de viajar ele tinha
passado nas escolas e vou preencher uma
ficha
vai que um dia o uniforme alguém quer me
contratar já tem meu nome lá o telefone
para ligar e um mal chega de viagem
depois de ter feito uma das experiências
mais malucas da minha vida e uma escola
me ligou perguntando se eu quero assumir
lamá sexta uma sétima série português e
inglês
eu entrei na escola é a sensação foi
aquela estou fazendo minha mochila é
mais um trabalho
é mais uma coisa que eu nunca fiz na
vida que eu vou lidar com ela
automaticamente acho que aquilo que
instrumentalizou eu já tinha nem um
pouco da formação acadêmica mas ninguém
tinha ensinado como é que se lhe dava
com o aluno com o pai
um colega principalmente na coisas que a
gente tem que aprender mas a gente vai
naquela vamos vivendo né
já chega o ano seguinte uma outra escola
faz contato comigo olha agora vamos
trabalhar no terceiro ano do ensino
médio e agora e literatura de mudou
matéria da série mudou tudo né
a sensação que a gente tem quando a
gente está começando a entrar numa sala
de aula em contato com o aluno é que a
gente está colocando o próximo trilho do
trem sempre procurei andar no trem não
pára e nós somos o responsável por botar
o trio quando parece que não vai colocar
a gente coloca o último trilho e o trem
segue passando a gente está tentando se
acostumar ainda com aquela idéia de que
puxa eu não sou mais o aluno que estava
ali eu sou professor e nessa hora falta
muito conteúdo falta muita experiência
por sorte sobra empolgação final do ano
informa que recebeu um convite para
trabalhar no pré vestibular
vamos lá naquela coisa mais um mochilão
continuando nos passar por mais uma
experiência mas ali eu confesso a vocês
que lhe aconteceu uma coisa
completamente diferente né porque essa
coisa de testar ser professor relacionar
com o público
o pré-vestibular ele ensina pra gente
uma situação muito particular
ali a gente não avalia o aluno e por não
avaliar o aluno para de competir contigo
para de tentar te enganar e ele passa a
ser seu aliado ele tv puxa tudo essa
pessoa que vai se juntar a mim pra nós
venceremos com meu objetivo e olha gente
tirar de cima do professor o controle da
disciplina o controle de tentar deixar
cargo porque tu tens que entender algo
que eu estou explicando isso alivia
muito o nosso trabalho
e foi ali que acho que eu percebi que eu
queria ser professor que estava gostando
da idéia de ensinar né
aprender a usar aquele conteúdo pra algo
é teoricamente é uma coisa muito fácil
nesse meio que tu pensas hora tem que se
preparar o aluno para passar uma prova e
tá tudo resolvido mas não é bem assim né
mas aí aquela coisa da diversidade que a
gente gosta de muitas coisas quando eu
vejo eu estou me envolvendo com
preparação de eventos culturais com
palestras estudando história da música
brasileira dando aulas no interior
também tudo acontecendo ao mesmo tempo
eo cursinho
indo quando de repente dá aquela dúvida
o que eu vou fazer da minha vida né
porque assim a gente vai sendo
atropelado pelos convites pelas demandas
eu pensava poxa eu e você professor de
pré vestibular professor de cursinho a
vida inteira
há uma certa caricatura em cima disso
também né parece que é um lugar muito
especial que a gente ocupa nisso fui pra
fora estudar quatro anos né fazer uma
grande estudo sobre a história do exílio
da tropicália e nesse meio tempo eu
comecei também a receber convites para
aulas em universidades para trabalhar de
tradutor jornalista tudo acontecia eu
acho que foi essa última experiência que
chegou e reuniu em mim tudo que está
precisando eu quero ser professor e eu
agora tenho orgulho do espaço que eu vou
ocupar esse espaço que está entre a
escola ea entre a universidade é um
ponto de passagem mas é um ponto
fundamental porque eu pego um aluno que
ainda não está focado na sua área
profissional específica portanto eu
tenho chance que ele me ouça ea
preocupação é essa né é a gente
conseguir fazer com que a comunicação
aconteça
eu tenho muito prazer assim de na vida
do dia-a-dia de compartilhar um filme
que eu vi uma série uma música que eu
gosto de dizer para alguém porque eu
gosto disso porque que é bom
e essas coisas que a gente vai
observando a gente a gente acaba levando
o trabalho eu vou levar para a sala de
aula
mas por que não tentar compartilhar com
o meu aluno que a jovem que é curioso e
todos são o prazer do conhecimento mesmo
trazendo conteúdo né
isso depende de eu falar daquilo com o
mesmo prazer que eu tenho em gostar
daquilo machado de assis por exemplo
pode ser muito chato
muita gente acha que o êxito né nós
vamos pegar uma cena talvez vocês
lembram alguns de vocês um livro chamado
memórias póstumas de brás cubas em um
momento em que o brasil está viajando
pela europa ele vai montar um jumento
para viajar e quando ele monta o jumento
empina ele cai no chão o pé dele fica
preso no estribo e ele percebe que o
bicho vai disparar
ele vai morrer naquele exato momento do
assalto um homem um almoço greve um como
em que cuida de jumentos segura o bicho
e coloca no chão
ele tem uma coisa tudo aquilo é esse
homem salvou a minha vida
um homem salvou minha vida eu tenho três
moedas jornada bolsa votar todas as
moedas para ele vai ficar rico
ele está olhando pro homem ele vai
mexendo a mão na bolsa e ele começa a
pensar mas acho que uma moeda de ouro
suficiente pra deixá lo muito felizes eu
nunca vi uma moeda de ouro na vida dele
quando ele mete a mão na bolsa ele tira
uma moeda de prata
ele fica observando o homem embora feliz
beijando aquela moeda que ele nunca viu
na vida dele pensa o homem ficou muito
feliz com aquela merda de parte de prata
poderia ter dado mais cobre quando nós
analisamos essas cenas nós conseguimos
pensar os grandes artistas eles têm uma
capacidade ímpar de observação da
natureza humana que muita gente não tem
e é com isso que a gente comece a
observar um mundo em que a gente vive e
como a gente atua nesse mundo todo né
esse tipo de raciocínio mesquinho não
têm época no lugar a gente ver um homem
do século 19 nos dizendo isso reconhece
no ser humano de agora é por isso que a
gente olha para o passado a gente não
mexe em um livro velho porque a gente
gosta de cheiro de naftalina a gente
olha para o passado porque a gente
percebe que essas coisas são constantes
do presente né
alguém já pensou nisso resta nós apenas
lewis são pérolas como essas que vão
fazendo um aluno uma aula por exemplo
pensar puxa que boa essa idéia desse
livro escritor é bom olha tem vontade de
lula mas sabe que essa disciplina para
não ser tão chata quando parece né
e eu fico pensando respeitar um aluno
meu caso é fazer isso não é só revelar
pra ele coisas estão ali que ele pode
vir a descobrir mas também permitir que
eles se encante com essa descoberta
a descoberta tem que ser dele porque nós
autorizamos aquelas descobertas que nos
interessam né
e aí vem essa questão para que nós
aprendemos aqui que nós aprendemos
alguma coisa e quando eu penso nisso eu
tento não fazer disso uma resposta mas
um caminho o caminho é a gente
continuasse pressionando sempre porque
que algo está sendo apreendido porque
com isso a gente leva para a sala de
aula precisa
uma vez eu terminei uma aula com uma
aluna sozinha e ela ficou pensativa e
acho que está havendo na hora disse o
professor literatura não serve pra nada
fiquei chocado como assim o trânsito não
serve pra nada professor só serve para a
gente refletir sobre a vida
a morte a humanidade a paternidade a
filiação o sempre uma coisa interessante
né
é o melhor sorriu ironicamente e foi
embora
eu faço o meu trabalho isso de uma
maneira muito responsável pelo que os
alunos querem cara tem que ter uma nota
uma prova mas eu sempre fico pensando
que saber não pode se esgotar em uma
prova não sabia em que adiante
eu acho que a forma de fazer com que
isso permaneça sempre dentro de uma
pessoa é fazer do gosto o método é
mostrar o prazer que a gente tem com
aquilo que a gente está lidando né
porque pode ser que seja a última vez
que eles entrem em contato com coisas
tão variadas antes de fecharem a cabeça
deles e se fechar dentro de um conteúdo
uma vez um profissional me disse olha eu
sou muito bom no que eu faço porque eu
sempre fiz a mesma coisa sem muitas
transformações sem muitas mudanças
achei interessante reflexão dele pode
ser para alguns ser assim mas eu acho
que isso não funciona para todo mundo
porque todo mundo é diferente
no meu caso tem uma longa experiência
acadêmica sem dúvida mas as experiências
profissionais e pessoais variadas foram
que acabaram me colocando no lugar em
que eu consigo me colocar eu acho que a
gente precisa pensar o que a gente foi
eu não sei se eu escolhi ser professor
eu não sei se escolher professores de
literatura mas eu escolhi dá um sentido
nas coisas que eu faço é nós precisamos
de muitas ferramentas de tradução gente
para as coisas que a gente faz para que
nós fazemos algo que faça algum sentido
para quem está nos ouvindo e as nossas
vivências pessoais e as nossas leituras
principalmente ajuda muito para tudo
isso
alunos ex alunos internos alunos
espero que isso também tenha feito algum
sentido muito obrigado
[Risadas]